I'm June Sarpong and I'm the author of
diversifying diversify looks at the
social moral and economic benefits of
diversity is it a critical ingredient to
be diverse and inclusive to be a
successful business and my answer might
surprise rusik no but it is a critical
ingredient if you want to stay there
people will not notice your the
diversity high when you start smashing
it out the past two days before I got
into Harvard the funding buddy contacted
me to say that my sponsors had defaulted
so I wouldn't have the funding I had to
face the stark reality that I'd have to
crowdfund to get that 64,000 pounds a
month you raise sixty four thousand
that's a I was in a business where the
blackmail was not a model figure that
was supposed to be the person going out
to win jobs and be in industry in this
radically changing world if your
business is built on the assumption that
diversity inclusion is a nice-to-have
it's an unstable territory in case
you're wondering Bane stands for black
Asian minority ethnic we have to realize
just what racism is and people don't
like the R word but we have to use it if
we're gonna get this stuff fixed if
we're gonna clean this stuff out because
yes it's uncomfortable
we're awkward but it's real and we have
to look at why we think the way we do
and it's not about being judgemental for
me it's understanding where this stuff
has come from how you one picket and
then what the new thing is that we're
trying to create and I think that's the
exciting bit
[Music]
so Alan what have you got for me this
time well I thought this time this came
from the equalities and Human Rights
Commission which looked at an analysis
of labour force survey data and it's
comparing pay for the same occupation so
this is if you like a lens through which
you can start to see how more
differently are people being paid for
doing the same job and this is like for
like this is this is the gap compared to
white British men I think this is a
really striking chart because one of the
things that you can quite clearly see is
it since 2008 since the financial crisis
the pay gaps widening it's a situation
that's getting worse and it's not the
same for all minorities like so actually
Chinese men for the same occupation are
actually being paid a slightly more yeah
one of the one of the suggested reasons
the Pakistani and Bangladeshi men doing
the same job are likely to be younger
for example so there could be some age
element here you're in the realms of
speculation because we don't know enough
what the factor shows us is intriguing
one of the things it does show us is
that there is likely to be a
discriminatory element to this because
those gaps are pretty wide in some
categories it's one of those things
where you want to break it down even
further and start to understand some of
the dynamics affecting each of these
particular groups if I show you the same
chart but for women yeah what do you
think and there's actually quite a few
groups which are being paid more than
white British women to the Chinese yeah
but some similar trends as well again
are worsening since 2008 this is when we
head into unconscious bias territory for
sure yeah and we have to call it out we
have to talk about this absolutely and
also I think it just shows you the
problem of just referring to as a single
category kind of babe
yes as a single thing right like it's
not about that you can clearly see that
it's not very interesting with a black
Caribbean group yes it is it's really
very interesting I mean in fact
particular on the women's chart what's
interesting is that
the fact that it's going in the opposite
direction to Pakistani Bangladeshi and
black African categories and how much
Black Caribbean women outperform their
men yes exactly that's something that
means yeah that's right because on the
chart yeah they they have completed one
trajectory completely brunette so this
states is fascinating because it just
encourages you to ask more questions
we're certainly not any sort of endpoint
that says right you know here are all
the answers to all the questions but you
know rather like with the gender pay gap
when we were talking about that we said
well you know the first step is having
some data but it really is just a first
date so and shriti and karen the
mcgregor review found that if bain
talent progressed at the same rates as
their white counterparts an additional
twenty four billion pounds could be
added to the UK economy each year there
is enough evidence isn't there in terms
of you know the mcgregor review or
whether it's about the McKinsey report
that shows that those companies which
are more ethnically diverse outperform
those less so by 33% in the latest
update of the diversity matters report
so in 2001 the bane population in the UK
was worth 32 billion in 2011 it was 300
billion that's a huge audience you're
missing out if you don't really think
about how you communicate and how you
enroll them in your particular
organization and your business as a
purchasing power so I think facts and
stats speak for themselves in terms of
you know evidence that more diverse
teams tend to be more productive teams
and more profitable teams but also in
terms of the purchasing power but race
is hard to talk about and in a boardroom
it's one of those areas that still now
people feel uncomfortable talking about
it being in the room well Sheryl
Sandberg
encourages us to lean in what I say is
often we're not even in the room to lean
in what every organization needs to ask
itself is is everyone in the room and if
everyone isn't in the room why not and
what are you doing to address that
now I know as a black woman I am often
the only one in the room and that brings
with it some extra pressure in that I
know that I don't have the luxury of
being mediocre I don't have the luxury
of not being prepared and often I'm the
most ignored person in the room
therefore I've had to learn how to
volunteer my opinion I'm Rick Lewis I'm
chairman and co-chief executive of
Tristan Capital Partners when I first
got here it was a bit of a shock I mean
I grew up in the States in the
post-civil rights us environment that
was encouraging of other people to get
into the workforce I don't mean that
there isn't prejudice there's an you
know bias but effectively whether you
call it affirmative action or help a lot
of businesses or at least encouraging of
a more diverse open workforce and I was
certainly a benefactor when I moved over
here I felt like I moved back into the
u.s. and 70s but I'd also noticed
something else that was really important
the difference is that I was regarded
and this is a shame but I was regarded
differently English black folks and it
was something about like I was either
enough and well-educated from the right
schools and so I was included in the
clubs it seems like a paradox to me but
people that grew up in the system were
put in a box and their aspirations were
contained whereas I didn't feel that
container the intersectionality of race
and class is something very important
that we all need to understand because
often we don't allow for nuance when it
comes to vane if you look at the beim
individuals that are actually
progressing in the workplace that are
getting to senior positions they are
just brown and black versions of the
white people who are progressing in the
corporate world and I think we need to
take this one step further I think we
need to open it out we have to figure
out how
make sure that regardless of a person's
background that we're able to pick that
talent and bring them into our
organization and allow them to be
themselves probably the most interesting
data set to look at is the data set
that's been produced by the social
mobility commission and what that does
is it breaks down the country into the
324 local authorities and it ranks them
based on a whole range of different
indicators about how well each local
authorities performing and what I mean
by performing is basically what are the
prospects of a disadvantaged student
that's what we're really growing up in
that area and this is the overall
ranking of social mobility for England
in 2017 and so what we've done here on
this map is just divided it into the top
half and the bottom half the green areas
here are the top 50 areas and the next
50 areas so Green is high social
mobility these pinkey areas are the ones
which are at the bottom of the social
mobility rankings for me this is a
really interesting map because this is
not a map of the haves and have-nots
it's the map of where do I stand a
chance where where am i chance is going
to be greater if you look at the moment
London here on the social mobility index
map comes out very very well let me go
to the overall index it's it's this sea
of greens and these top areas if we
actually look at a different measure
which is deprivation London looks very
different so we're breaking it down to
much smaller levels which is why it
looks like much more of a mosaic you
know a similar sort of color scheme in
that the pink here is the more deprived
areas the green is the less deprived
areas and one thing that you can see
here is that London is not that
continuous wash of green we know that
London plus is a city of contrasts we're
going to zoom into an area that you
might be just a little bit familiar with
which is forests and so here we've got
our colouring of deprivation and you can
see that within the borough obviously
there's this color scheme is about a lot
of pink
yeah and this is the top 10% nationally
most deprived this brightest pink so in
a national context that's quite deprived
there are some pockets of green as well
what we're going to do here is now take
this color and reinforce it with a bit
of a treatment that bring
out into a much more different but what
this is kind of showing us is that you
know the cliff edges that you've got
this is deprivation where these are the
highly deprived areas I'm just
interesting we've got the sea of green
surrounded by love this deprivation
that's why it's really important to
notice that that the haves and the
have-nots don't have to live miles away
from each other I know for myself
without having gone to a really good
state school there's no way I'd be where
I am today we had amazing teachers who
just expected the best from us
it was incredibly aspirational and even
though there were so many of us that
came from quite poor backgrounds we were
around children who came from relatively
affluent backgrounds we could see that
there was a bigger tomorrow the
intersexuality of class is something
there Andy Haldane touched on imagine
this is the chief economist of the Bank
of England someone who presents is the
embodiment of privilege and power but
sometimes you can be surprised along
some dimensions everyone feels like a
minority right so I was the first white
middle-aged middle class yeah and the
point I joined the bank I was the first
wave of state school northerner Wow
right so for most of my bank career
which is a long time now I've actually
felt like an outsider despite looking
tall intensive purposes inside and
there's something of that I think in
everyone you know everyone's felt a bit
of an outsider some of the time and
asking everyone to think about the
situations where they were put in a
slightly vulnerable position yeah might
be inside work might be outside work is
actually I think very important I mean
the social mobility dimension is we
needs a push yeah
gender is moving too slowly but it's
moving ethnicity issues are moving too
slowly but they're moving social
mobility is going backwards on many of
the metrics what about bringing those
voices into who we employ it's almost
the most invisible form of
discrimination that we have
going on which is particularly UK in the
UK you know the categorizations the sort
of the accents everything how we judge
and who we bring in yeah it starts so
young that you almost sort of really
embedded that before before these kids
grow up and then another child and also
what we lose out on as a society in
terms of the cultural influence in terms
of actually shaping what Britain is as a
nation when we're not unleashing the
potential of so much of our citizens
makes no sense I want to see the people
that I grew up with authentically
themselves in senior positions of power
being able to run organizations without
having to conform and I don't know how
you get there and I don't know if
perhaps I'm asking for too much at this
stage but Rick Lewis certainly has ideas
one of the things that we found in the
data is that when it comes to race often
you find that the type of people of
color that succeed within the corporate
structure have often gone through
perhaps the Russell Group system or are
themselves from actually quite middle
class backgrounds so my question is how
do we change culture so that wherever
there's talent talent has a chance to be
developed I think the aspiration of
having the talent pool be truly the
widest it can possibly be in diversity
of all things including sort of
socioeconomic background and upbringing
and you know bias and leaning would make
sense the unpopular thing that I'm going
to say is that any pathway to progress
starts with the pioneer stage where some
people get in that are different but
those people that are deciding are
comfortable with and they start to
change it I truly believe that that's
where we are I saw that happen in the US
I think that's what's happening here but
I think we have to be realistic that you
know as we get in the inside it's
incumbent upon us to keep the pace of
change so keep the conversation up keep
the fight up and then when you
a chance when one gets a chance to
change the mix to broaden the room to
help people often subconsciously get
comfortable with difference that's the
moment so what is social mobility look
like in action the first step in in
changing our aspiration bubble is you
have to see yourself in the movie then
you have to believe that you belong in
the movie and there's a whole thing
about affording the movie and getting
some support to encourage when you
stumble along the way in the movie hello
my name is Isaiah Wellington Linh I
crowdfunded 64,000 pounds in four weeks
the fund my place at Harvard after my
scholarship for three campaigners called
Stratford to Harvard I think this
location is very special because
Stratford used to be a very deprived
rundown area for there's a lot of
poverty and it still is to some extent
but I think this part of Stratford
represents progression and regeneration
and I think that's been a large part of
my story that's right and knew him again
it's a very similar pattern here to
Waltham Forest because actually they
both score very very highly on the
social mobility index and we were
looking at before so these are areas
that are you know scoring very very
highly on social mobility but overall
deprivation is striking striking don't
you and me really got a tiny patch
that's right in new him virtually
everything is skyscrapers of deprivation
and it will be really interesting to see
the next release of that's right where
there's been a targeted investment to
try and address some of the
long-standing problems do you think that
those regeneration that happened in this
area impacted you in the sensor perhaps
had there not been an investment in his
community do you think that maybe your
story wouldn't have been possible I
think my story would have been possible
because of the people I had in my life
who ensured that regardless of the
limited resources around me I was still
able to pursue my potential so my mom
and are the key mentors they tell me
about the Harvard project
it was interesting because Harvard
wasn't one of the options really I
created it as an option for myself and I
remember speaking to a few of my tutors
and they said that's not really going to
be possible it'd never been done before
knowing at least on my background who
had a similar story to me I just made
sure that I was persistent I provided
all of the materials that my tutors
needed to write my references and get to
know more about me and then I applied
and then two days before I got into
Harvard the funding buddy contacted me
to say that my sponsors had defaulted so
I had to face the dark reality that I'd
have to crowdfund to get there and I was
very apprehensive about doing that
because I knew how much work energy and
you know to be honest varner ability or
take for me to share my story and evoke
the kind of support I needed and it hit
me once I got to Harvard that I occupied
so many competing identity as a young
black boy of African Caribbean heritage
haven't grown up in in London that was
like one identity and then growing up in
a low-income deprived learn parent
family was another identity having
studied at top UK university was another
identity I was thinking okay why don't I
fit in here
there was no one who I could reach out
to you yeah fully identify with I mean
that was very difficult very challenging
and I must say at times I felt like
going back to London I was like okay
I've worked so hard to get hurt so
you've done a lot of internships and do
you think do you think race has played a
role in that in the sense that you know
that perhaps things are not equal it's
not a level playing field so therefore
you need more on your CV then your white
counterpart I must say it's very
draining draining in terms of the work
you have to put into applying for these
internships but then once you start it's
also draining because there's this added
burden of race and it's not something
that I can escape it's not something I
can peel off in the morning and then put
back on in the evening it's kind of
there all the time but actually when you
bring in masculinity and race that's a
different experience in terms of black
men being seen as a source of fear a
primary source of fear and what that
represents when you're in the corporate
world and how people relate to you yeah
so you hit the nail on the head that was
another element of my identity that was
also in conflict and I had to find
different ways to mitigate against you
know misconceptions everyone faces
impostor syndrome to some extent but
when you're the only different person in
your team you face a whole nother level
of impostor syndrome can you explain
that more so it's kind of a constant
battle and it can have quite shocking
you know impacts on how you navigate
different spaces because often
second-guessing every decision that you
make it can lead to intense anxiety do
any executives watching this wanting to
get diversity right wanting to figure
out how to create workplaces that people
of color can feel welcome and people of
color can thrive in what's your advice
to them my advice would be that we exist
and there are people in this world in
London in you know in the UK who occupy
many different identities and therefore
are able to understand how best to
create and design an experience for
different people multiple multiple
people and I think that's the key that
you're not just hiring a black person
you're hiring someone who comes with a
suitcase of experiences of how to
navigate particular spaces and then when
you translate that into corporate value
is exponential that's priceless
I think Isaiah's story shows us just how
broken our system is imagine had he not
been so entrepreneurial there's no way
he would have made it to heart
and think of the countless isaiah's that
are being lost through the system
because there's nothing in place to make
sure that these kids who have the
ability for the potential are also being
provided with the finances to be able to
fulfill that potential it shouldn't take
such a sectional talent such
all-consuming determination the people
of color from disadvantaged backgrounds
to get access to the corporate world
what would you say to any business
leader or HR manager terms of number one
why it makes sense to go and actually
seek diverse talent particularly talent
from vain backgrounds and number two
what is the thing that they can do to
make sure that that talent feels
welcomed within their organization
there's a couple reasons the first is
just that you're missing out on the
whole population that's really talented
and why wouldn't you pick the best and
brightest of the entire basket rather
than just a portion of the basket so
that's one reason the second is that you
know times are changing and the crowd
the rebel crowd is going to start to
form at your door it just is it's like
so if you rest on your laurels sooner or
later it will catch up for you I think
that one recommendation I have is broad
is think about the culture of your
department your group your organization
and your business and is that well
suited to accomplishing these business
goals and if it's not start to change it
yeah but that change is hard if you're a
big organization if you are a footsie
company fortune 500 you've been around
for decades and decades in some cases
centuries how do you change culture how
do you do it baby steps
start moving it's the same recipe it
just may take you longer to change
culture and change the numbers what's
your opinion on targets and angles yeah
I like aspirations I words like
aspirations and vectors and and targets
rather than quotas I just I think that
there's a negative connotation to sort
of filling a certain number I think if
you I mean that this is I'm going to
take it easy
well perhaps but I think if you start
talking about what you're trying to
accomplish and what you believe will
help you accomplish that you start
rounding into an approach it's funny how
when it comes to this issue
we don't wear uncomfortable quantifying
because you know I don't know a single
company a single successful company that
doesn't set itself financial targets and
everyone within that organization knows
what they're working towards and what
the company is expected to generate in
terms of income by such-and-such a time
and it's funny how when it comes to this
we want to be a little bit more relaxed
I think you're right but I think there's
two reasons for one for and one against
I think it's a matter of trust
if you don't define the hard target your
I think what you're saying is one could
mistrust that you actually have the
intent to achieve it I think that's fair
I think the other part that I think
where people are careful is saying a
couple of missteps and then people will
stop trying I think we need to redefine
where we place diversity within the
company structure at the moment it tends
to fall under CSR we see as a charity
thing a nice thing to do but actually
this needs to go into R&D research and
development because if you are a company
that wants to be around 50 years from
now a hundred years from now then
diversity is essential for your survival
and this is where you must invest
you